- Il n'y a aucun doute pour
la commission d'enquête,
l'assaut du Capitole était
une tentative de coup d'État
fomentée par nul autre que
Donald Trump.
Images, documents, témoignages
à l'appui, ils décortiquent
minute par minute le déroulement
de cette journée fatidique.
Un des témoins,
le documentariste Nick Quested,
filmait la milice des Proud Boys
ce jour-là.
Dès 10 h, avant le discours
de Donald Trump, le pepepe se
dirigeait déjà vers le Capitole.
"Je n'ai pas le droit de vous
dire ce qui va se passer,
dit-elle, mais il va se passer
quelque chose."
Tous diront plus tard
qu'ils répondaient à l'appel
lancé par Donald Trump.
"On a été invités par
le président des États-Unis",
hurle un des manifestants.
Et c'est ce que plusieurs
d'entre eux di
à la commission.
"J'ai cru que ces élections
étaient volées, dit-il, et
Trump nous a demandé de veni
"Je savais pourquoi j'étais là,
dit-il, c'est parce qu'il
m'avait ded'd'd'd'être là."
"Nous sommes du même côté,nenee
vous", dit-il au policier.
Des images rythmées par
des extraits du discours
de Donald Trump ce jour-là.
Le jour où la démocratie
a vacillé aux États-Unis.
Une dernière photo avant
l'assaut.
Selon un des enquêteurs, tout
ceci était planifié depuis
la victoire de Joe Biden.
Le leader des Oath Keepers
avait écrit à ses membres :
"Nous n'allons pas laisser
passer ça sans une guerre
civile."
On apprend également que
le soir du 5 janvier, le leader
des Proud Boys et celui des
Oath Keepers, Stewart Rhodes,
s'étaient rencontrés dans
un stationnement souterrain
à Washington.
"Le président Trump a convoqué
la foule et allumé la mèche
de l'attaque", dit-elle.
Après ce commentaire de Donald
Trump lors du débat télévisé,
le leaPrPrPrPrProud Boys
répond : "Nous sommes prêts".
"Diriez-vous que le nombre
de Proud Boys a augmenté après",
demande l'enquêteur?
"Ça a triplé", répond-il.
On apprend aussi que
l'entourage de Donald Trump,
incluant sa fille, était
en désaccord avec l'idée que
les élections lui on
volées.
"Je n'étais pas d'accord avec
lui, dit son ancien ministre
de la Justice. Je lui ai dit
que c'est de la foutaise."
"Ça a affecté ma perspective",
renchérit Ivanka Trump.
Liz Cheney, une fervente
républicaine, lance un message
fort à ses collègues.
"À mes collègues républicains,
dit-elle, qui défendent
l'indéfendable, un jour viendr
où Donald Trump sera parti, mais
votre déshonneur, lui, restera."
Joe Biden, quant à lui,
lance un avertissement.
"Les mêmes forces qui ont mené
au 6 janvier, dit-il, sont
encore etetetetetetet c'est toue
la démocratie qui est en jeu."
Ici Azeb Wolde-Giorghis,
Radio-Canada, Washingto